great well uh hello everyone uh my name
is Karim Butler and I'm the director of
the global economy and finance program
at Chatham House
and on behalf of fathom Consulting and
Chatham House
it's a great pleasure to welcome you to
this afternoon's discussion on what's
next for UK monetary policy
and we've timed this as I'm sure you can
see to follow yesterday's Embassy
meeting
uh this is a new departure for Chatham
House I think I've only been here two
years but I think in two respects uh
firstly in the sense that this session
will have a quite a strong
domestic uh UK economic Focus
um and we typically events here and have
a more International flavor however we
felt that
um the last couple of months
particularly 23rd of September and
what's coming shortly
um
uh has had really quite considerable
International significance and I came
back from Japan yesterday and it was
amazing how everybody was talking about
this one way or another
um now it may well be that this is uh
not in terms of spillovers more in terms
of demonstration effect but it just
seemed important for us that we should
cover this here
and the second thing is that uh to
before we get into the panel discussion
we're going to have a um serious
economic forecast or presentation
Outlook from fathom and I'm extremely
grateful to to Eric and his team for
putting that together but I think that's
going to be very good
uh context for the discussion that we're
going to have
uh just a reminder of the sequence so
first of all Eric and Laura from fathom
will do the presentation of their latest
Outlook we'll then move to the panel
discussion
um with four members former members of
the monetary policy committee and
fathom's chief Economist uh will have
presentations from the panelists and
then a debate and that after that we'll
open it up to questions from the
audience and we're also going to
sprinkle throughout the event a number
of
survey questions
um and uh we'll have those done by Sligo
which I'm very confident our experts
here will make happen very smoothly so
we'll have some survey questions as well
I should note that this is this event is
on the record
and as well as the in-person audience
here we have an online
audience as well and that's drawn from
fathom's contacts and also Chatham House
contacts and members
and also if I could ask you to uh when
we get to the discussion to try and keep
your questions and comments as succinct
as possible
because uh we have a hard stop at half
past five which I think is slightly
shorter than sometimes these these
events have been
so first to the uh Outlook presentation
this is going to be given by Eric
Britton who well known to a great many
of you is CEO of fathom Consulting
um previously had a very distinguished
career in economic Consulting and at the
bank of England working in the monetary
analysis area on the inflation forecast
and he's going to be joined by Laura
Eaton who's the chief operating officer
at fathom she's an expert model builder
I'm absolutely fascinated because she
does quite a lot of model building on
the Chinese economy which must be quite
a challenge but nonetheless very
important to do so Eric and Laura over
to you for your presentation
thank you very much
thanks crayon and uh welcome everybody
what they're wonderful to be in person
with the actual live audience of people
and those who are joining us virtually
too
um
you enjoying the ride so far the last uh
last few weeks is fun right this uh
spent many years we had this monetary
policy Forum starting in 2009 uh in the
teeth of the financial crisis back then
and we ran it for 10 years quarterly
after 2009 during which they moved
interest rates not once
10 years of quarterly
sessions what are they going to do with
rates the bank of England nothing again
nothing and it got to be a little bit
dry towards the end of that well it's
not dry anymore that's for sure so here
we are we're talking about this let me
welcome Laura to the stage who's going
to be sharing this presentation with me
it's wonderful to be here at Chatham
House and thank you so much Creon and
everybody else involved from Chatham to
make this happen
right
um emergency monetary policy Forum
emergency for reasons that I'm sure are
obvious to everybody I'm hoping this
clicker will work over to you Laura yeah
so thank you for coming today so fathom
is predicting a recession everywhere is
the gloomy picture that I'll begin with
um the top right charts here you can see
the gold dots is consensus and fathoms
projection for both the US and your
early GDP growth is below that the green
line is our Central projection
so
the differentiation is going to be
across economies in terms of GDP growth
which is the next
next chart which looks at terms of trade
so this is export prices relative to
import prices and you can see the green
line here is the US which is standing
out to be much higher than everyone else
that's dropping and the reason for that
is that the strength in the dollar due
to the safe haven assets is reduced
import prices for the US consumer and
then also it's a net energy exporter and
there's obviously benefited from Energy
prices rising so much so we see the us
is going to be faring much better than
some other economies in the in the
near-term future
contrasting that to China the bottom
right chart there's a large downward
skew in our projections for GDP growth
and that's owing to our 15 probability
of it entering a banking crisis in the
next few years or so
taking a step back we've just had the
steepest recession of all time followed
by the steepest recovery of all time due
to monitoring fiscal loosening so having
this pause in growth is to some degree
to be expected
the question is how large is that poison
growth going to be so generally you can
always find someone worse off than
yourself and normally that person sorry
Andrea is Italy however in this case
unfortunately it does appear to be the
UK
and it's easy to blame the budget for
the current malays in the UK economy um
very easy to do that so let's go right
ahead and do it and this is uh what's
known I'm gonna the term more than more
on premium is attributable not to me but
to Dario Perkins I believe
um and it captures the effect that uh
the budget uh the mini budget announced
by quasi quateng the trust government
had on financial markets that you can
see very clearly there in the spread
between UK 30-year index linked yields
and the U.S counterpart they're just
rocketing up we've never seen movements
like that for for decades really in the
in those relative positions and it's not
just in the um guilt Market it's also in
the value of selling basically all
Sterling denominated assets were
revalued rapidly as a result of that
budget Sterling tanking back in 2019 we
at fathom put together a bunch of
scenarios that assessed what the
possible Market reaction to a Corbin
government would have been at that time
and it turns out
um
markets in the past have driven labor
governments of course within the space
of a a few weeks a couple of months by a
very strong reaction to the proposed
policies that those governments have
announced we looked at the one in the
mid-1970s the Wilson lib lab pact of 74
and the impact that markets had in that
time
and we thought that in 2019 the markets
might respond in a similar way to a
Corbin government and if they did that
would have been the magnitude one Corbin
let's call it and on the spread in in
the linkers market and one Corbin on the
valley of Sterling
we thought this was a market reaction
that would correspond to a far left
labor government or just a left labor
government of any sort in fact half of a
Corbin half of one Corbin has transpired
as a result of
a conservative government the budget
announced by uh quasi-quarting
um half a half was in our fit transpired
half of half of a Corbin was sufficient
to drive that budget off the rails the
budget all of the measures in that
battery have subsequently been reversed
and it's now in tatters as a result
which is exactly what we thought would
happen to a Corbin government
at the time we did those Corbin
scenarios we're told there's no way
markets would be would behave in that
way there's no way they would react that
strongly but they've done it now with
the Tory government or at least half as
much
um it's easy to blame the malaise of the
UK economy on the budget on the trust
government on kwaziquating it's easy but
instead we prefer to refer to trust as
the shore that break the cams back so
you should also focus on what was
overburdening that Camel before she came
into power
so thinking about the top right chart
the dark blue line and casting our mind
back to the monetary policy form that
took place in February 2009. where the
panel that you'll see later was calling
for unconventional monetary policy ieqe
at the time I hear that Diane said that
QE could be alike into an affair it's
very easy to get into but very difficult
to get out of to which Charles responded
but maybe she was getting into the wrong
types of Affairs
um so I'll let them debate that later
but in terms of QE Deanne appears to
have been correct so 2009 QE then again
in 2012 the Euro error crisis and then
QE on steroids in response to the
pandemic 2020
monetary financing direct lending from
the bank of England to the government
and a much larger scale than was
introduced in 2009 in response to the
global financial crisis
why did they do that well the bottom
chart thinking about steepest recession
of all time including the World Wars
including the Spanish flu and also the
plagues in response private income Rose
and that happened because of the large
amount of government loosening that took
place
then a couple of months ago quantitative
tightening was introduced vitally this
removed the put option for the investors
and the market so no longer were they
saying I will not let Government Bond
prices fall that was removed and that
was the context in which trust announced
her unfunded tax cuts when the investors
were watching for the fiscal
sustainability of their plans now you
need to look at the fundamentals of
fiscal policy again the bank of England
had announced that to the world and then
they did the unfunded tax cuts in the
budget and that's why the markets
freaked out to the extent that they did
scrolling back a bit it's not just that
we're facing a recession now it's not
just that we've been through this
convulsion related to the budget is also
we're in in double-digit inflation and
thinking about that inflationary
environment what's Driven it there's
been a bunch of what's known as first
round effects out there that have
contributed to it the first one
captured on the top left chart there is
the shift into Goods consumption this
this is the share of consumer spending
that goes on Goods across a bunch of
different countries over a long period
of time that trending down year after
year after year decade after decade as
we consume more services as a share of
our overall basket
reversing during the pandemic period why
because we couldn't consume Services
you're not allowed to travel you're not
allowed to go to restaurants and
Hospitality Etc the consequence of that
the share of goods increased and it
wasn't just a share it was the absolute
spending on Goods increased everywhere
really quite dramatically stretching
Global Supply chains causing the
increases in shipping costs and a bunch
of other things that we saw during the
pandemic and adding to the cost of
living really for everybody around the
world including the UK
and then it's as if that weren't enough
we had that nice Mr Putin doing his
thing in Ukraine invading Ukraine and
the impact that that had on Energy
prices at uh especially gas prices
especially in Europe and in the UK no
less than than elsewhere all of these
are first round effects they're going to
drive the price level up gonna drive the
cost of living up policy makers monetary
policy makers correctly should look
through the first round effects and
ignore them when it comes to setting
interest rates think about the second
round effects is there any evidence that
those first round shocks are Rippling
through to wages are starting to affect
firms prices who are not directly
impacted by these things they're
starting to feed through into other
prices in the economy that's the stuff
that policy should be squeezing out
what is the second round what about the
second round the bad news is there is
pretty clear evidence of second round
effects in most economies around the
world including in the UK there's four
charts here that
give different perspectives on the same
question
top left chart there is the degree of
pass-through from non-core
consumer prices which is the sort of
volatile bits that move up rapidly move
down rapidly into core consumer prices
so the non-core bits are the bits that
pick up these first round effects
question is is that Rippling through to
core consumer prices answer yes across
the oecd as a whole that's the blue line
it's that degree of pass through has
increased dramatically the us as well
the Gold Line the UK I would say the
jury is out on this point but it's gone
down it's gone up again it's gone down
again I would say the jury is out of it
on in the UK on that point however the
jury is not out on wages on the in the
labor market which is the top right
chart here what we're looking at here is
the blue bars of this are wage growth
over a certain period and the green bars
are CPI inflation over the same period
real wages are falling everywhere that's
not the point I'm making here the point
I'm making is nominal wages can only go
up by the inflation Target plus
productivity growth if they're not to be
in flesh a source of inflation in the
economy capturing second round effects
the inflation Target's two percent
productivity growth in the UK roughly
naught
um anything for north of two therefore
is an Evidence of second round effects
in the labor market it's pretty clear in
the UK in the US less so I would say in
Germany
that's pleased
yeah I mean you know there's other
factors in play there which will come
back to a separate conversation at the
bottom left chart
um is a picture of wage price
correlations in the UK over a long
period of time and it turns out that if
you've got inflation CPI inflation
running at less than five percent really
there's not much relationship between
CPI inflation and wage inflation but as
soon as CPR inflation gets above five
percent you start to see this upward
sloping relationship it's okay it's
quite loose it's quite poorly defined
where are we now is the Green Dot in
that chart which is took in that range
we're above five percent on CPI and
we're starting to see it picking up
along that upward sloping relationship
albeit towards the bottom of it evidence
I would say of the beginning of a wage
price fire I'm not we're not fully in
one but maybe there's evidence of it and
the final chart here is the degree of
persistence in inflation so to what
degree is inflation now
equal to inflation over the year up to
now and uh if if that persistence is
high it's it's indicative that The
credibility of the monetary Target two
percent is low and uh there's a there's
a indication of a higher degree of um of
second round effects in play in the
economy in the UK it's all the way back
up now to where it was in the 1970s in
the US it's about half the way back to
there
none of these charts is a slam dunk
should be clear about that you could
have this degree of inflation
persistence occur just because you've
had a series of unfortunate events that
push first round effects up over a
staggered period of a couple of years it
would still look a bit like that however
taking the whole panel together I think
we conclude anyway that there's pretty
clear evidence of second round effects
at play in the UK economy the question
is the Judgment for central banks is how
much monetary tightening is needed to
squeeze them out
enough to cause a recession so you can
see why we've arranged drinks afterwards
this is all quite gloomy so far
inflation at current levels has almost
always triggered a recession the
recessions in these charts are shown by
the vertical gray bars
one school of thought says higher prices
and naturally self-correcting thanks
their impact on real income and real
profits but as Eric's just shown there
is evidence quite strong evidence of
second round effects and so we believe
that the bank of England amongst other
central banks are going to need to tie
to more more than they did yesterday
and therefore that is going to result in
a recession particularly in the UK
quite likely in other countries too it's
not just the current recessionary
environment we should be bothered about
though we should be standing back and
looking at the macro policy environment
in the round for the last decade and
more and the news on that front I would
say is very Bleak the headline says it
all macro policy in fathom consulting's
view over the last decade really since
the great financial crisis maybe before
has been a disaster
and this tells you why this is the
growth and well the level of GDP on a
log scale so you can interpret the
slopes of these lines as growth rates
the level of GDP in the UK is the blue
line and here's the great financial
crisis the recession that occurred there
we never recovered back to the
pre-crisis trend and furthermore the
trend post crisis was slower than the
pre-crisis trend was this was growth
rates like two percent this was growth
raised like half to one percent in the
UK
has to be said that that same shock
occurred right across the G7 which is
the the green line there and in fathom's
analysis if you've been paying attention
over the years one of the big
contributory factors to that reduction
in Trend growth post GFC was the shift
to permanently ultra low monetary policy
permanently below interest rates which
uh stifles productivity growth for the
reasons that I could go on about for an
hour I won't do so here you'll be
delighted to hear
reduction in Trend growth post GFC and
to a much weaker Trend over that whole
decade
doesn't stop there this is the pandemic
period what's the Judgment that we
should pass on the macro framework that
was in place during the pandemic well
the impact on GDP in the UK was
substantially worse than it was across
the rest of the G7 that judgment is
therefore on that those grounds alone
was pretty bleak there were other
factors in the mix of course brexit to
name one but uh notwithstanding that but
just the the impact of the pandemic
itself on the level of GDP was much more
pronounced in the UK than elsewhere in
the G7
you might take that trade if you thought
well I'm prepared to trade a worse econ
outcome for a better health outcome if
the health outcomes in the UK were
better than the rest of G7 you might say
fair enough they weren't they were worse
than in the rest of the G7 worst econ
outcomes worse Health outcomes the
Judgment of the government in charge the
macro policy environment chart at that
time has to be really pretty bleak
two percent Trend growth roughly half to
one percent Trend growth roughly
naught percent Trend growth roughly
roughly we are overheating with growth
at naught in the UK
um if that is not a damning indictment
of the macro policy framework I don't
know what is there has to be a better
way than this please tell me there is
yeah that's why we're here today
hopefully to find a better way
so in summary top left fairness
forecasting a UK recession consensus has
moved towards us on that point and
yesterday the bank thinking has too
top right we expect inflation to Peak
above 10 percent
bottom left we're going to need more
interest rate hikes maybe six percent
over the next year or so and that's
going to push up the long end of the
yield curve how do we get out of this
mess and do a better job in the future
and this comes to a long run and a piece
of analysis that we've been doing over
many years in fathom this is the
relationship I've cheated with the axes
here and apologies to Chris jars if he's
here I know this is something that
exercise a lot of people the axes are
not the same so with that caveat in mind
but what we're looking at here is the
real bank rate the dark blue line and
the four quarter growth rate in whole
economy productivity the green line and
you there's lumps and bumps and wiggles
and jiggles and all of this stuff there
always is but broadly speaking since the
early 1990s there's been a downtrend in
both of those Concepts growth slows and
we cut interest rates we cut real
interest rates growth slows again and we
cut them again growth slows again and we
cut them some more
we do this for decades
what point do we think do you know what
maybe cutting real interest rates
doesn't just stimulate demand in the
short run maybe it also undermines
Supply in the long run and that's
basically fathom's perspective on this
whole conundrum we were in a similar
environment to the one we're in now back
in the 1970s there was a decisive moment
in British macro policy at the end of
the 1970s which is captured in that that
red oval there maybe we need another
such decisive moment a reset of the
macro policy framework in the round in
the UK that's what we're calling for
that's what I think we need to think
about in this session and Beyond
that's it thank you very much
[Applause]
right
um well there's a great deal to think
about there and um
what we're going to do to kick off with
is actually have our first uh survey
question so I think the survey will
appear if we could
do that
um
and the first survey question is to what
extent
we don't have it yet okay maybe we'll
have it very shortly
right to what extent has the NBC
fulfilled its remit
since the pandemic hit
and we are
okay
somebody that
um
so so I'm not it's possible it won't so
what we have done is put the survey to
the online audience I was assuming that
we would get it here but if we don't not
to worry because I can certainly see the
results coming up here
uh and so this will be an online
um view you got it okay
uh and it's still moving around a bit
um
so if you can that would be great
those you can
okay and uh
still moving around a bit maybe we will
okay well why don't we freeze it there
so if we um
no you haven't voted yet okay okay
uh
okay why don't we freeze it there so if
we can we show the results uh yeah
so um
very interesting
very interesting there we are
so I think they're the
okay so uh so I think that's good to
have a survey um and what we're going to
do now is have a panel discussion
um with a a really distinguished group
of experts four of whom are here in the
audience and one of whom is online and
has appeared now online
uh and the focus is going to be on a
number of talking points
um either through the initial comments
all through the subsequent discussion so
as is indicated from the survey we've
just done talking points to include to
what extent has the NPC fulfilled its
remit since the pandemic and I guess you
know was the decision yesterday the
right one to take uh will it be
necessary for the bank rate to move
above inflation to get inflation under
control at some point in the coming six
months or so
um why have even long-term interest
rates uh risen so much and this I think
you can see from index linked guilds uh
the yields when you look further out and
I guess this is a way of asking to what
extent
um has the Prime Minister trusses
policy experiments over the last uh six
to eight weeks or so again I have
long-term consequences and then finally
just to add from a Chatham House
perspective you know one of the
international implications
um of what the UK has been doing on
monetary and fiscal policy
um and both now but in the coming year
and so to respond to those talking
points and also the presentation that
we've seen we're going to kick off first
with some comments from uh Andrew
bridgen right at the end Chief Economist
at fathom uh and also a forecaster at
the bank of England so along with many
others in fact the bank of England
background so Andrew over to you thank
you very much Creon
um I'm going to speak for a couple of
minutes and so we can give much more
time to these other distinguished
panelists so I just want to draw out an
emphasized three points really from from
the presentation and and the first one
is that I think you know we shouldn't
maybe with hindsight but we shouldn't be
surprised by double digit inflation it
didn't come from nowhere and if you
think analytically what did we do during
the pandemic and I think it was
completely the right thing to do we
asked the bank of England or the bank of
England decided independently to print a
large amount of money this money was
transferred in the UK to to workers who
were who couldn't work so we basically
said on condition you don't work we're
going to print some money and give it to
you you know any kind of monetary
economics textbook will tell you if you
print money and to pay it to people on
condition they don't work you're going
to get inflation and that's what we did
and also we said oh by the way you can't
spend it for a bit because all the
things you enjoy doing are shut and so
of course as soon as we open the
floodgates globally all this money
that's built up around the world was
spent and we got inflation so you know
the plus side is we know helicopter
money Works we're debating whether
helicopter money could be used to get us
out of deflation well it can
um if you do it powerfully enough and
but then I think you know in defense of
the bank of England in that situation
you know we weren't the only country
doing this the US was the being the
largest economy was the largest
contributor to this big buildup of cash
around the world so you know even if the
NPC had tried to tighten early last year
could they really have kept UK inflation
under control If the Fed wasn't doing
the same I mean yes if Sterling
appreciated hugely but that's perhaps
unlikely so you know the bank of England
have got have got and had a difficult
job
second point I just want to talk about
quickly is persistence I think where we
differ from the bank of England and why
we think interest rates could go up to
six percent is the that's the the mean
of a very wide distribution in our fan
chart is that we're much more concerned
by second round effects than it appears
the NPC are you know they say it's
something they're looking out for
something they're watching for well
can't you see it I mean I think they're
a very clear second round effects now
um you know our view is that in terms of
inflation persistence the extent to
which inflation depends on what
inflation was in the previous period
rather than dropping back down to Target
my view is that's gone kind of halfway
back to what it was like before
inflation targeting
um and the risk is that it goes further
still and that's why we had such a wide
franchise for inflation we just don't
know honestly where how persistent
inflation is going to be but I think
that's why we differ from the bank of
England view
um and perhaps also you know the bank of
England is getting increasingly
frustrated by market pricing for
interest rates trying to tell them
you've got this wrong by several hundred
basis points and you know and nothing
happened yesterday to you know market
pricing for short-term interest rates
hasn't changed so maybe investors are
kind of coming around to that view as
well I mean we can perhaps debate later
why you know why investors are taking
such a different view from from the bank
of England
um you know and then finally you know
they do the bank of England is well I'm
criticizing them indirectly now it's
quite easy to criticize them they have
got a very difficult job they're clearly
aware that we're in a cost of living
crisis and you know we
when I was studying economics many years
ago and we were talking about the
optimally conservative Central Banker
you wanted some Nutter who cared only
about inflation to get things under
control but you know these are humans
These are nice people they know there's
a cost of living crisis and then asking
them to tighten aggressively and put
mortgage rates up it's a difficult
decision but you know that they're
they're independent perhaps but they're
human and they can see all the reaction
in the press and you know so I guess
from an inflation targeting point of
view my guess is there's going to be a
natural tendency for them to hope for
the best rather than take aggressive
action and I think hoping for the best
was certainly what they were doing
through much of 2021 until that became
untenable I guess
you very much and yet certainly the TV
yesterday was all about the consequences
of this it's quite quite striking how
um the media's focus is entirely in that
area perhaps understandably so next
um I'm very pleased to welcome William
Balto Who's online uh William was one of
the first members of the monetary policy
committee an external member from 1997
to 2000. he's currently a senior fellow
at the council for foreign relations
previously Chief Economist at Citigroup
and at the BRD and also obviously also
has a very wide-ranging academic career
so Willem over to you for your initial
comments
thank you it's a pleasure to have a
chance to speak here
um
in the NPC the bank of England
uh it's behind the curve I mean rates
Paul Savage RNC percent now
um which is just into restrictive
territory there should have been in
restrictive territory but uh earlier and
uh more aggressively
um the same applies to the quantitative
tightening which has uh finally started
we're going to do 80 billion on
Wednesdays tightening a year at that
rate it will take 10 years to get rid of
the APF that you build up so with this
it's very modest uh but the Titan is
going on they can't be blamed for
um all of the inflation outbreak
um the NPC like everyone else was
surprised by covid but Ukraine war and
by the sanctions
um this is unlike any sharks since the
oil price of the 1970s
um but uh and also like most other
central banks and many economic
observers and analysts they got the
temporary and transitory nature of the
supply sharks from them in the UK for
instance the labor force participation
rate is significantly lower than it was
prior to kovid that's a permanent supply
shop activity rates have weakened in
addition I think more gradual negative
Supply shocks different demographics
declobalization the bifurcation of the
economy between the U.S Senate and the
china-centered block
um the um
the cost of building up redundancy
moving from just in time to just in case
reassuring and onshoring it does affect
productivity growth brexit for the UK
has been managed very badly I think it
was a disaster itself but given that
brexit has occurred the Regulatory and
fiscal changes to take
advantage of other deaf opportunities
are there potentially has not been taken
and finally I think uh the bank
still to recognize just the magnitude of
the fiscal and voluntary policy response
to covet and to the energy and commodity
price shocks
um
so where do we have to go
um I agree if it's the earlier speakers
that bank rate will probably hit uh six
percent in 2013
um I do not
follow the bank's monetary policy report
analysis where
um
projecting current
Market
interest expectations which speak at 5.2
in 2023
um now we have inflation uh well below
Target at 1.1 percent by 2024 second
quarter and we had zero percent in Q5 in
fact so in 2025 in Q4 so
um uh similarly the implaus ability
that of the projection that we're three
percent rates maintained throughout we
could actually get inflation uh back to
Target again I think that's dreaming so
um if uh rates for 23 likely higher than
uh the markets currently project
but as a result of the recession this
will cause the rates could well be
somewhat lower late in 2024 and 2025.
and real interest rates fiscal space I'm
one of those who believes that the 800
years of declining real interest rates
have come an end to an end for uh most
of the world uh the demographic
deglobalization
um
and all the supply side developments uh
the weakening of extante
private savings as a result of
demographics so I see the fiscal space
is gone less stress and crazy quiet
tanks budget was insane and got punished
by the markets I hope the world learns
from this and
comes to the conclusion that R minus G
negative is not going to be something
that you can rely upon I'll stop here
well then thank you very much a lot of
points uh I'm sure we'll want to come
back to
um but next I'd like to turn to Charles
goodheart uh Charles was also one of the
first members of the NPC an external
member uh he's the Emeritus professor of
banking and finance at the LSC and as
almost everybody will have everybody
here will know he was the author of good
Hearts law and has had many other roles
including actually when I was at bank
chief economics chief of the bank's
Chief only advisor so Charles over to
you thank you Korean it's a great
pleasure to be here at Chatham House
particularly since it's not going to be
under Chatham House rule
I'm going to try and make three comments
uh the first one
is that pushing up interest rates has a
lot of nasty effects on the economy
higher mortgage rates
declining employment and so on and so on
and fairly soon into the process of
raising interest rates there's going to
be more and more suggestions about is
there not another way to combat
inflation
and that undoubtedly will tend to lead
us back the wage in price controls we
tried that in the 70s and the 80s we
tried it to destruction and it turned
out to be pretty much a disaster
and some of that has been learned but I
think not all because there is I think a
growing danger that the form of wage
price control that the present
government May adopt is controls over
public sector wages
and we've heard comments about the
possibility of them to be held back down
not only this year but next year to
numbers that are really quite extremely
low
and if they try and go ahead with this I
think it would be a disaster for a
number of reasons first it will mean
that the provision of our public sector
Services health education defense and so
on which is not good at the moment we'll
go down further
second the industrial disruption which
we now have
you can see about you will if anything
get worse
and third it actually I don't think will
succeed I don't think that Great British
public will will agree for example to
nurses wages next year being held down
to two percent until to the low levels
of the present
uh if I may then com comment on one of
the things that fathom was saying if he
was divided wages into prices in public
I think you would find that the weight
price borrow with respect to private
sector wages was already well underway
and much more obvious than if you look
at wages as a whole and I think that you
actually ought now because of the
attempts by the government to hold on
public sector wages to make that
division between private and public
sector wages
uh I'd like to turn to a few comments
about uh the fathom uh presentation
almost all of which I quite largely
agreed with first one is why did central
banks get it wrong
I don't think that they got it wrong
because they didn't understand that
there was a lot of pent-up demand and
that a lot of people had quite a lot of
Bank deposits and they knew all that
where I think they got it wrong was
because they didn't see the tightening
of the labor market that was going to
occur when the vaccines were introduced
and actually
fathom you should have mentioned
vaccines and you didn't and then you had
their way up
they thought I'm J Powell quite clearly
thought and I think the bank of England
also thought that come the Autumn of
2021 there would be a huge flood back of
Labor and that that would offset the
increased demand that would come from
the workers who are now back at work and
had a lot of money
um and I think it was the tightening of
the labor market
uh effectively as William said
um that uh put the move
uh
um on the half of corbyn uh I think that
it is
dangerous to attribute all of that to
the unfunded expenditure it was also due
to the frictions that were caused by the
particular aspects of ldi in the
problems of the Pension funds and I
think a lot of the increase I in good
edged
yields initially were due to that
Paul tuck I heard Paul Tucker actually
arguing on a video conference that all
the increase in gilted yields related to
other countries was due to these
frictional effects of ldi and I would be
delighted if somebody who is both better
and closer to it than me could actually
try and distinguish how much of the
effect and guilt yields was ODI and how
much was sort of underlying concern
about the quieting budget and unfunding
um I simply do no
then again on productivity I'm less
upset by this productivity decline than
most I in my view quite a lot of it is
simply a result of failures of
Statistics to be able to estimate
productivity properly and we have moved
from a manufacturing economy
increasingly into a service economy and
service output is frequently as just
estimated as inputs today uh I mean
three years ago I never heard of Zoom
now I can communicate with people all
over the world at the drop of a hat and
that has made my productivity as an
academic which would otherwise be
declining sharply uh very considerably
higher than it otherwise would be
now the final comment that I want to
make is that in all these discussions I
think there's far too much emphasis on
the immediate short run and where Peak
interest rates are going to go I very
much agree with Andrew and Pat them and
against the bank I just don't think the
bank of England has a leg to stand on to
say that you could get inflation down
while holding interest rates of three
percent it's crazy what they what a
model that that's based on I mean Ben
broadbed had an odd model which we
published which I didn't understand a
few weeks ago and
I'm not sure I believe it in fact I'm
sure I don't
um I I when I one of the problems is
that we have been moving from a period
as I've written open of having sort of
available labor Supply particularly if
you can shift your production to a low
wage economy coming out of your ears to
one in which the labor Supply is going
going to be much shorter and people are
getting much more worried about
reassuring to safeguard your supply
chains and all that is going to push up
uh inflation
and fairly sharply effectively what that
means is that the natural rate of
unemployment is going to go up and going
to go up really quite sharply and
because an increase in the natural rate
of unemployment is going to be highly
unpopular I don't think that the bank
either will or will want to raise
interest rates anything like enough
to bring inflation back to two percent
they won't do it and it won't be done
with the result that in my view the idea
that we're going to back going to go as
the bank suggests relatively easily and
painlessly uh once things start turning
down and the energy prices start coming
down back to you know I'm with Willem
and the the idea that we're going to go
back down to sort of two percent in 2024
and people read below that in 2025 it's
a mirage
in order to do that we'd have to have
unemployment so much higher for longer
it's just not going to get done
and I think that the inevitable
projection is going to be a period of
stagflation which isn't going to
necessarily be all that horrible and
what's wrong with three and a half to
four percent for random in inflation and
somewhat higher unemployment
um and you know we struggle on it's a
lot better than it than things could be
that's enough Charles thank thank you
very much
fascinating points there uh and now to
our next speaker
um named d'angelia so I'm very fortunate
to have a as a colleague here uh in
chathamel she's a distinguished fellow
in the global economy and finance
program
uh she's been chair of UCL she's been
chair of Chatham house
um and she was also one of the initial
well yeah the initial members of the
monetary policy committee so Deanne over
to you thanks for that introduction I
guess I should also claim that I was at
one point an advisor to Fathom when they
first got going advising them partly
that it was time to get out of the bank
of England to do something in the
private sector
so I'm glad it's worked out
I think
just as when we were all on the
committee we did not coordinate our
views ahead of time we waited till we
had a good discussion so it's been
interesting for me to hear what what
villaman and Charles have said and I
think actually we have a little more
agreement than I thought we would
I started my preparation for this this
panel by saying are we really in an
economic crisis you know this is an
emergency meeting how how much do we
feel we're in an emergency
and I think my view is that we've had a
net we as a country have had a narrow
escape from what could have been a real
crisis
that was not just the budget although
that was certainly the trigger or the uh
the straw that broke the camel's back as
Laura was saying
but remember we had a summer of
virtually no government at all at least
no Effective Government
and indeed it was announced that no big
decisions would be taken during that
time so from the Market's point of view
this was a a period in flux Without
Really knowing what was coming and
that's partly why there was such an
extreme reaction when they discovered
what was coming although a lot of what I
think was simply the facts of what was
being being proposed there
if anything we were saved from a real
crisis by what uh is sometimes called
the British constitution which I've
never understood because of course we
don't have a constitution in this
country but but we do have some fairly
solid institutions and we do have a lot
of precedent in dealing with these kinds
of crises and this was a case where the
chancellor got put by the wayside very
quickly the bank of England stepped in
and put a stop under the under the
guilts market uh pretty soon the Prime
Minister was gone and then miraculously
a new person showed up to be prime
minister without another election so a a
very shocking chain of events from the
point of view certainly of the markets
that don't reside here in in London
but although we didn't have a crisis in
my view we are still in a post-crisis
very vulnerable situation we still have
very high inflation the housing market
is beginning to Wobble the the strikes
in the railways and elsewhere are coming
up in fact tomorrow
and if anything we have to be extremely
careful with policy including the
monetary policy for the next few months
it strikes me that what the bank
produced yesterday in its in its
forecast
I also like my colleagues who've already
spoken and perhaps those who are about
to speak I also found it really
unbelievable particularly the the
emphasis they put on this constant three
percent interest rate and I think part
of what's wrong there is that there was
very little uh very little analysis
about what difference it makes to the
exchange rate you know we've we heard
Jay Powell we hear that they are going
full stream ahead and they're indeed
influencing expectations that interest
rates will go up from the four percent
where they are now at their cap
whereas here our governor is saying
they're not going to go up even above
five I think that's extremely dangerous
vulnerable for Sterling and of course if
Sterling does go into a significant
slide then that pushes up inflation and
you're into just the wrong kind of cycle
as a monetary policy committee
and of course external factors are also
very uncertain you know it we don't know
how the war in Ukraine is going to play
out we don't know how volatile Energy
prices and grain prices are going to be
we don't know what the budget's going to
look like for the next couple of weeks
but I think despite the level of
uncertainty the the direction of travel
is pretty clear that interest rates need
to go up and they probably will need to
go up quite significantly
I I think I would say between five and
six somewhere but I wouldn't put any
money on it in the sense that who knows
I do think that if you looked at the
bank's Central projection by the end of
next year end of 2023 inflation was
still five percent but a little about
five percent would they really not be
raising interest rates anymore if
they're in a situation like that maybe
Charles is right and they won't
um but I think there's a a very good
chance in my mind that they would still
need to be raising interest rates even
if they pause or take smaller steps
immediately
and just to go on with finally with with
sort of the medium term where do we see
this coming in in the longer term
I mean there I think we will see
inflation come down over the next six
months it's almost
um assured because of the base effects
uh coming through but given the
uncertainties in the geopolitical
environment including the U.S election
and how things go there I think
inflation is going to be pretty volatile
because Energy prices will be volatile
and these second round effects will be
volatile
so I think that it it will be the case
that the bank really needs to look more
at core measures of inflation uh and
make sure that it is targeting the right
thing and not simply
um the volatile headline headline rate
I also felt that it's important to think
about some of those underlying cost
pressures that come from what villain
was talking about for example the
geopolitical tensions the the fact that
um
it's going to be difficult to get
semiconductors in various countries and
that's a key input to many of the things
that we consume inventory building for
resilience all these things add to costs
of of industry
and even if Charles didn't mention it I
was very struck by his demographic
discussion in the latest book about
China and what's happening there so the
global
supply of labor is of effective labor is
certainly going down and that of course
will push push inflation up
so it's it seems to me that in addition
we've got on the investment side of the
equation uh big demand for some of the
the energy transition Investments
there's demand for additional military
spending in a number of our countries so
looking at the savings investment
balance leads me to conclude that real
rates natural rates are likely to be go
up not not down
uh and I did just as a matter of
comparison look back at the time when
all of us were on the MPC
um the the normal range of interest
rates during that time was four to six
percent uh and at the same time
inflation was a little bit below too and
the economy was growing reasonably well
certainly well compared to today's
looking back so it seems to me the era
of ultra cheap money is over whether
because of the reasons that fathom has
come up with or that Charles has talked
about or that we all are recognizing
when we read the newspapers every day
about Ukraine I think we we have to get
away from this uh this zombification if
that's a real world
and get away from the asset price
bubbles that have held back growth
Dan thank you very much and now for our
final introduction from sushil wadwani
so sushil is currently the chief
investment officer of pgim wadwani he
was also a member of monetary policy
committee not quite from the start I
think but pretty close to the start 1999
to 2002 he's worked in Goldman Sachs to
do Investments as well as having a
number of academic roles and
appointments and social I don't know if
in the course of your
discussion you're able to answer
Charles's question about you know how
much of what we saw in terms of yields
and so on was due to actually market
failure rather than expectations because
you were probably a better place than
anybody to answer that question I'll
make an attempt thanks it's in any exact
science but thank you very much it's the
privilege to be here uh it's also a
privilege to be reunited with these
three you know we were the Infamous Gang
of four
so it's it's great to be together
um now uh
I knew I was going last and therefore I
knew that many of the things I wanted to
say would be said by these very clever
people
um
and I also knew that they would be
giving the banker hard time so I'm going
to first start by saying one or two nice
things about them and and then and then
go on to other things so
um
I mean obviously everyone has
acknowledges it's a very challenging
environment
it's really really tricky I remember
Rachel telling me 20 years ago maybe or
yes around 20 years ago that actually
any assessment of the inflation
targeting regime could only reasonably
be made once the economy
faced a challenging environment and that
what we then thought was a challenging
environment was nothing compared to what
might happen and and you were completely
right as always
um
and I think the second thing is a lot of
people and we saw that in the poll
results earlier say that
you know they would have raised rates
earlier they would have run round QT
earlier you know I was certainly in that
camp last year uh in public but
you know if I'm truthful to myself I
would probably raise rates a little bit
on Mount QT a little bit inflation might
have ended up at seven or eight rather
than ten but for the Great British
public it would have still been a dismal
failure I've been seven or eight versus
ten who cares it's you failed
um
now having defended them I have to say
that
I mean you know I look at them they're
very clever people they're very nice
people
they're very knowledgeable and I sort of
but I'm really puzzled by some of the
things they're doing and saying
um
and you know I sometimes wonder whether
I'm just too old and that's why I don't
understand why
they're doing what they're doing uh
but uh but you know as fathom have said
I mean the second round effects are just
at least to
someone like me just seemed completely
obvious and it they're obvious even in
their own decision maker panel survey
that they run themselves or they help
run themselves you just look at those
numbers uh these are not uh firms whose
inflation expectations are on any
definition anchored if you look at the
inflation expectations over the next few
years even three years out
they're very high you know their
acknowledgment that they're willing to
accommodate High wage increases is
apparent in that survey
and yet for some reason they don't Place
enough weight on evidence of that kind
um
and
uh
I here I will be repetitive but I I was
just really really puzzled by
yesterday so on the one hand they did
the right thing and put rates up by 75
basis points
and I would have thought in terms of the
impact on people's expectations out
there they largely unwounded them by
talking about how rates possibly may not
need to go up very much more maybe three
percent was it uh it just seemed
pointless I mean you've just put them up
by 75 beeps at least don't undo any
benefit that you might get from that
um
and and the notion that anyone can be
confident uh in terms of knowing where
rates uh are going I mean I just find
that fanciful if if you think about
how wrong the consensus has been how
wrong the bank has been in terms of
where rates would be now
it's just
really odd to me that anyone could have
confidence you know I'm supposed to
stake my clients money on on betting on
interest rates but I really just take it
take each day as it comes I don't sit
here thinking I know it's going to be
five percent or six percent
really
one just has to respond to the data and
I mean my sort of uh simple advice to
the bank would be
you know they should just copy what
chairman Powell Mark II is doing rather
than Mach 1 obviously uh but but
chairman Paul Mark II has kept it really
simple
all he says is that he's determined to
bring inflation down he knows that if he
doesn't bring inflation down it's going
to be damaging and he'll do what it
takes and he doesn't know what that
means but monetary policy will respond
to the data and and and he'll do what's
necessary
and and that's much much simpler and a
much more credible message
uh than we're getting from the bank
um anyway
the other thing that really puzzled me
was a remark from the Deputy Governor
one of the Deputy Governors yesterday at
the press conference
where he said that it was the duty of
markets to listen to what they said
rather than for him to pay any attention
to what the markets thought I mean I I
just found that
unbelievable when I was in the NPC I
always
felt that I actually knew remarkably
little and that was really important to
learn from other people
and I'm old-fashioned enough to believe
in the wisdom of crowds type of argument
and think that it might just be that
little bit of information in markets now
having said that
obviously I've tried to make a living
out of the excessive volatility in
markets and I recognize that they can
and do get it wrong
but having said that to then go to the
Other Extreme and dismiss all
information from the markets struck me
as incredibly dangerous to think that I
that we have a Deputy Governor who
thinks like that I found profoundly
worrying
um
the other thing which I wanted to raise
I know I'm about to run out of time so
so so to my two last points yes uh
another thing that they really puzzled
me with is their attitude on QT
and this was reiterated at yesterday's
press conference so they said yesterday
that actually none of us should worry
about QT it doesn't really matter and it
doesn't matter because they're not
trying to send a signal by doing it in
terms of future rates and the second
reason which I found absolutely
extraordinary given what's happened in
the last eight weeks
is that
QE only matters when market conditions
are difficult and since presumably
market conditions are great now
uh QT doesn't matter
it was absolutely extraordinary
and my last point Sorry Sorry Creon is
I was surprised I have to say Charles
You Were My Mentor when I was first uh
appointed to the academic staff at the
LLC you are my official Mentor you may
have forgotten that
but I was very surprised to hear you say
that it's kind of okay to let inflation
drift up because obviously that's the
thin end of the wedge one's hearing this
argument everywhere Jason Furman raised
at Jackson Hall
a lot of other people are bringing it up
it seems to me this is incredibly
dangerous but I'll just stop that
brilliant so uh we are a little bit
behind but we will we will catch up no
no worries
um what we'd like to do now just is have
another poll uh if we could uh get the
poll question up
uh and this time I was rushing things so
I will be more more a bit slower in
allowing people to um
to put their questions up and I think
you can also respond here online and
also people can respond
[Music]
um
so I think we're waiting for the next
one yeah here he comes
so if everybody would like to respond to
that
hoping that's the question we're
expecting yeah
not many people I'm not quite sure what
everybody can see online but maybe the
same thing as I can see
um
okay uh
so that's very interesting because I
know that's not what Eric thinks so we
might come back to that shortly but it
seems to be quite a strong
exactly
um now I have a I have a vast number of
questions but I know that there are
other people in the audience who
probably have much better questions than
me so I'm going to restrain myself at
least to the end uh and gather some
questions from the audience but also
invite our online audience to start
putting their questions in and
um magically I should be able to pick
some up from here as well
uh but let's start with um the audience
here and if we could kick off perhaps
with two or three so the gentleman over
there first of all thank you hi uh Ed
Conway from Sky News thank you it's it's
really nice to be doing these things
again and thank you very much to to
Fathom for putting it on uh I'm getting
quite nostalgic about those days when
interest rates didn't change
um one of the one of the Striking things
obviously about the meeting was as as
pretty much every panelist has alluded
to was that attempt to try and influence
the market and obviously then it was
striking to see that the market listened
to to that and were like wow we don't
really buy that and it did and it didn't
happen I just wondered how how much do
you think that was strategy from the
bank how much do you think it's delusion
in terms of having a kind of forecast or
indeed a kind of idea that interest
rates at that level are going to be okay
so how much of that is strategy versus
delusion going to kind of to Charles's
point about whether stagflation is kind
of what their
is seeing us heading towards and
secondly just how much does it matter if
you have a loss of credibility which it
feels like maybe we're in that kind of
Realms where the market and pretty much
everyone on the panel has a completely
different Viewpoint to what the bank
does on interest rates how much of a big
deal is that in the future when it comes
to policy when it comes to the economy
and where we're heading
thanks very much if we could just add uh
I'm sure there are other questions in
the audience so does anybody else want
to close a question alongside that one
uh yes one win if you'd like to bring
the mic forward and just there should be
a mic coming your way this if this one
here please if we could just go to this
one first thanks
and just to say I know who you are but
um but I'm on the website Board of the
obr actually
um among other things
um I want to ask social a question about
the market because
one of the things that happened was
credit spreads jumped and no one's
talked about the yield curve as a whole
and I wondered if
um what you thought about that I mean
I'm not surprised but should we be
looking or should the bank be looking
more at the overall tightening in the
market because credit spreads really
jumped a lot
excellent so let's take those two
questions in that one together and who
would like to go first
um
social why don't you go first in the
world okay so I'll start with Ed's
questions
so uh
I mean
I think that their loss of credibility
matters hugely so certainly when we were
all at the bank
we used to think it was you know really
convenient to have an extra sort of
tool
so you you moved your rate and then you
did
you know in some subtle way perhaps
trying to influence expectations and it
was incredibly helpful to have that
auxiliary tool
um
and uh the uh and therefore and
therefore it was really surprising to me
that they were willing to allow those
two things to operate in the an opposite
direction yesterday
uh but credibility also matters for many
other reasons so uh
you know when big events happen big
shocks happen uh the fact that people
have typically believed the bank really
matters and you saw that in a small way
in the recent guilts crisis where they
hardly had to spend anything
um so it's a very very precious asset
and it's sad to see them
kind of sort of beginning to lose it uh
but in the response to the question of
you know is it
that they they know that this is not
fully in line with what the Mandate
would say what you should be doing if
you actually have a two percent Target
in nine versus
and therefore they're just because they
they're worried about the consequences
for you know cost of living and that
kind of thing versus the fact that they
have a different analysis to the members
of this group here which because I think
that was the question that was being
asked which of these two things is it
you think in your view
is it that they actually know what they
should be doing but I just don't think
that
the public could accept this at the
moment or is it that they actually have
a different model of how things are
going to work
model because I mean at least the
individuals I know are sincere
hardworking honest people yeah and it
could be
outrageous for me to cast aspersions on
on their degree of honesty yeah okay um
okay anybody else like sorry sorry do
you want to go to bronwyn's question as
well
so I want to make sure yeah
I mean I assume they do look at credit
spreads and I would be very surprised if
they didn't
so uh I mean certainly in in our MPC
chart pack it's been I mean I've I've
been off the committee 20 years so my
memory isn't as good as it should be but
my men from what I recall we were you
know it was very much in the chat back
and we did focus on it
uh but but it's possible because you
also talked about across the yield curve
and
and and and that sort of uh I I that
reminded me that I didn't uh answer
Charles's question to me about ldi and
everything so I think the ldi shock
clearly was a very large part of what
happened to 30-year Guild spreads versus
say the U.S
and that that is very much where the
shock was concentrated in the 30-year
area
um
for what it's worth the many UK Pension
funds and Consultants I've spoken to
since the shock
uh
I mean
my two penny worth would be that they've
all adjusted very very meaningfully now
and they're no longer a source of a
future shock
I mean in terms of what actions they've
taken in terms of rebuilding liquidity
and the actions that they've taken in
terms of
reducing the Hedge ratio
which is being very meaningful
and in some cases as you saw with
Sainsbury's yesterday you know the
parent companies arrange a cash infusion
as well so if you put all that together
I don't see them as being a material
source of risk to the guilds Market
unless yields are go up another 200
basis points or so at that level I think
they could become another source of a
source of risk yet again
uh but your question was across the
yield curve and we did of course see a
big UK fiscal risk premium at the short
end as well which I believe had nothing
to do with the unraveling of ldi
except to the extent there was a little
bit of contagion
but it was only limited so I think there
was a fit a risk premium which built up
there more because of Charles's argument
that Sterling was highly vulnerable
and that you could get a sterling
collapse because of uh
poor fiscal policy and then that would
then Force the bank into hiking rates
so thanks uh thanks very much maybe I
went on too long not at all no it's all
excellent stuff I come to DM next thank
you I wanted to just say something about
the credibility Point uh I absolutely
agree credibility is very important
particularly I think in in these
Economic Times when you know the vast
majority of the public uh I hope they'll
tune into this new broadcast about uh
you know the basics of you know what
does GDP mean and how has inflation
happen because I remember when we first
started on this journey
we used to mention 2.5 percent it was
2.5 in those days 2.5 percent in every
third sentence you know when we would go
out and speak in in the regions and so
forth and the idea was very explicitly
to get that anchor into people's minds
in a number that they could kind of
remember and against a measure of the
CPI or the RPI in those days that they'd
all heard of uh and I think that was
very important for domestic credibility
now I think the real difficulty that the
bank has with credibility is that too
much of their communication is based on
the forecast model
most people do not including most of us
I think in this room probably do not
really understand how the forecast model
works I think the members of the
committee do
um and it's changed over time but the
difficulty is getting through this idea
that this is I think they don't call it
a forecast it's a projection that it is
based on assumptions and if those
assumptions are right then probably the
outcome is right but the assumptions
aren't right they're never right they
can't be right
and that is too complicated a message
for most of the media certainly so that
the message becomes ah a two-year
recession because interest rates have
gone up to three percent uh you know
that
and although I don't know what what the
alternative is I think even the U.S case
where they just have this Dot Plot which
I'm glad we didn't have to do that
ourselves
um but that is maybe a better
communication device than the forecast
model is I'm not saying they shouldn't
have a model they should certainly use
it in the discussion but I think to make
that the main element of communication
has really been a disaster
what I'd like to do actually because
we've got a great questions coming on
board so if others could hold their fire
for a minute and we'll take some of
these questions now so one of the
questions is
um can you say what uh the bank should
be doing on the pace of QT
uh and where they're targeting shorter
dated instruments makes sense and that's
from Matthew elderfield it's a question
about QT
uh another question which kind of goes a
little bit to some of the points that
susha was making had the bank of England
raised rates to three percent prior to
the trust budget
to what extent would the market of
reaction have been different so if
they've moved earlier in a sense faster
and then uh final question if we just
take this is a question really about the
redistributional effects of
the inevitable kind of rise in interest
rates on the average person in the
country I mean how bad in a sense is it
going to be
as a consequence of uh
the levels of interest rates we're going
to need to address inflation and I guess
the implicit question then is in a sense
it's not the bank's job
to address those questions it's really
for the government
to respond to what the bank may need to
do in principle
so those are three questions and I
wonder if I could come to actually
William first of all online whether you
would like to pick up on any one of
those questions all of them potentially
but as briefly as you're able to do so
on
on quantitative tightening I already
mentioned that uh the 80 billion annual
Target is De Minimus
um I think at that rate it would take 10
years
to get rid of the portfolio that was
built up
since the the great financial crisis and
I think we're going to have to
move
um in a market-sensitive way
as quickly as possible
um always having an eye on the possible
Market disruptions and being willing to
intervene as the bank did appropriately
during
the kerfuffle between the 28th of
um uh September the 14th of October
um
pre-distributional effects of rate hikes
well they're there we all know about
them
um Borrowers
uh don't get hit
lenders savers
are smiling if this is a problem
socially then the government should
address it through the budget
the bank
cannot let itself
uh be influenced
by these considerations in terms of the
speed
or the magnitude of of its weight height
let me just uh up the front it's a quick
remark on anything but it was sort of
strategy or delusion
that causes the bank to
collaborate the C percent uh projection
I think it's a strategy driven by
delusion that this really is the wrong
model yes it's very hard to predict but
interest rates will be and I can't be
sure either but I am really pretty sure
that rates stuck at three percent will
not give us a below Target inflation by
2025 and so there's this this is the
wrong model and this undermines
credibility
and
um if you add to that statement that
markets should listen to the bank rather
than Bank listening to the market I
think javidia are undermining the the
future effectiveness of monetary policy
there has to be
aware they have to believe that you will
do whatever it takes to get inflation
back to the Target you may not know what
it is
but just as the bank
during the abroad in the markets said
that is intervened in any amount
necessary to restore stability before
they sent the 65 billion limit
um commit was simply I think a
short-term Target and uh it is
absolutely essential that the markets
believe that they are serious about
achieving the inflation Target within a
reasonable time Horizon thank you thank
you very much
um Charles is there any of those three
points that you'd like to I just like
Carmen and Willem it is awfully easy
to talk about being determined to get
back to your inflation Target when
unemployment is at an all-time low just
wait until unemployment starts Rising
say one two three percent it'll be much
much harder to go on saying I'm
determined to get it down to two percent
and I'm going to raise interest rates
Come What May
uh just think of the kind of political
Flack that you will get from doing that
but doesn't that make it doubly
important that they say it now
yeah and one of the things is when the
underlying situation is inflationary
you've got to raise interest rates early
on and buy a lot because you won't have
much chance to raise them later because
the political context will be against
you and that has been the error that the
central the bank of England has made it
is weighted and weighted and waited and
really it's too damn late
I know because the the clear comment was
made by the chief Economist there that
he got to raise interest rates a lot was
where we had the quieting many many
budget when we got the change of
government and uh the new Chancellor and
the suggestion that we're going to have
a properly funded fiscal policy I think
at the one percent or more had to be
taken off the table and if they tried to
go one percent or more it would have
been almost an in a statement that we
don't believe uh that
that the tsunag hunt will actually do it
and I don't think they were in a
position to make that statement okay
sorry William you were
did were you trying to no okay great
well let's get another uh set of
questions there's a gentleman here and a
gentleman in the front here and then a
gentleman but it'd be nice to have some
ladies as well if you wanted to put your
questions extremely welcome but let's
take the gentleman here first
mikhil Ramos a member of Chatham House
on the
um confidence in the Bank of England I
although everyone watching screens all
days of which I'm one of the people uh
may have all kind of views on this The
Five-Year five-year forward to inflation
swap it hasn't really moved in the US
that much or it isn't that worrisome
still so remarkably markets seem okay
with with what is discounted now is that
maybe because some of the data is
actually not as bad as what we've
presented before is it if we look at uh
built a crate if we look at
shipping rates I mean uh in my role I
cover a very big shipping family
privately owned who predict that
container rates will be below the
average of 2018-19 next year
simply because the
um their competitors have expanded
capacity with all these higher rates
that were there and demand is
considerably low Walmart said that for
this Christmas period they've ordered
considerably less Target is ordering
considerably less
um David roach an independent analyst
has stopped tracking the queues at ports
because there aren't many anymore and
the supply chains come back yes so your
question your point is that Global
deflationary questions May save us yeah
potentially yes question here
uh John gave xmpc for a few years
um I um I wanted I was trying to think
well you know what would the bank of
England be saying in uh to to the panel
about their forecast and I guess they
probably say that they were taking a
different view of the labor market uh
that they thought that the the wages
were going to be squeezed in real terms
really savagely and that alone would
produce the sort of deflation and
recession that will bring inflation down
whereas I think your view is that's not
going to happen unless the bank
puts up interest rates a lot more
aggressively so I just you might want to
comment on that one other thing on the
wage front
um I think it's going to be a critical
part of the fiscal statement what is
assumed about public sector
pay
um I suspect that they will take the
view that they can't let public sector
pay increase
within existing expenditure budgets and
that therefore they've got to have a
squeeze a freeze
um rather than taking the view that
they've got to top up public sector
programs in order to allow for a higher
rate of pay increase uh what would you
be advising them on that
thanks very much and then one ah one
question here very quick one and then
another question there yes uh thank you
my name is
originally from Japan my question is
about a spiral over effect or pressure
to and from the monetary policy of other
countries well so how would you or how
did you see the balance between
focusing on domestic inflation and the
Gap the gap of interest rates with other
major economies such as European
continent Japan and the US well Japan
for example is facing low inflation now
domestically but facing I mean a big
increasing a gap of interest rates with
other economies traditionally inflation
was country-specific issue but in this
case uh it's you could see some danger
of seeing that in a simple way thank you
so you it's your point really that the
interest rate Gap will lead to exchange
rate depreciation and yeah
is low okay and later here as well
hi Jonna Davies from fathom Consulting
something we've been thinking about
internally lately is what's the one
thing we would do differently with macro
policy Deanne I feel like you hinted at
that earlier in one of your other
responses it sounded like you were
suggesting a communication difference
something more similar to the U.S fed
perhaps but one idea from each of you
would be wonderful on that front thank
you
uh powerful questions so
um I mean Andrew did you well you
shouldn't answer the fathom question
obviously but I don't know if you want
to comment on on the other questions and
yes there's quite a few let me just try
and uh quickly remind themselves up and
so
um I think uh Sir John was talking about
um
uh real wages falling and perhaps that's
you know the bank of England's hope that
um you know that it will squeeze out
wage pressures and inflation will come
back to Target I mean that I think you
know there's been a lot of focus on the
fact that real wages are falling which
of course they are they're falling quite
significantly but you know is that I
think Eric and Laura were trying to set
out in the presentation I I still think
even though real wages are falling and
nominal wage inflation is is
inconsistent with the inflation Target
and I and that for me is part of the the
second round effect I mean if we're in a
situation where real wages were Flats so
um wage inflation was exactly the same
as Consumer Price inflation then you
know in that kind of world inflation can
almost become a random walk that's kind
of extreme
um second round effect so we're not in
that bad world we were in that world in
the 70s I would say for a brief period
of time where inflation was your best
guess of where it would be next year was
the 23 it was currently at
um so I mean it's good that well it's
not good it's good for inflation that
real wages are falling
um but I still think they're you know
that that nominal wage inflation is a
problem because it's not it's not
consistent with the Target and I think
you know that we've done quite a lot of
work looking at it there's an
interesting non-linearity which we'll be
trying to get across in the presentation
that when information is low sort of
less than four then the correlation
between inflation and wage inflation is
pretty much zero it you know you
inflation might be three percent this
year rather than two and an employer
might say well sorry you're only getting
two percent because it'll be two percent
next year and the worker might go all
right then you know I'll believe that
but when it's 10 they said well no it's
going to be two percent next year that's
all you're getting you know well no I
don't I don't quite buy that now and so
I think there's a point at which
inflation really matters for wage
inflation and the spirals start to build
up and I think in the private sector
someone was saying earlier it's
important to make a distinction between
the two and I think Charles and of
course it is it's there is a wage price
spiral in the private sector not in the
public sector yet and then to answer
your question I think again about them
what would we be saying if I was in
government what would I do I guess I I
think it's right to listen to the pay
review bodies and do what they say and
they will probably say to put wages up
quite a bit and and I would do that and
I would let the bank of England deal
with the inflation consequences probably
shall we
um we since we're very close to the end
I probably have to make this our final
set of responses so I don't know if
there's anything more broadly you want
to say just generally if we because
we'll I think we'll answer these
questions and also just any general
coins so
um
now I'll let the other speaker okay fair
enough uh sushil
um any of those questions you'd like to
pick on particularly Global inflation
pressures is there a chart deflationary
pressures is that going to help yes so
uh
I I think that what was being said about
shipping rates and so on resonates with
me I mean it's clear that there are
significant components in headline
inflation that are going to sort of come
off and and go in the other direction
next year so I have no problem with
headline inflation falling very
considerably in many countries next year
the the reason I remain worried though
is is that I think core inflation in the
US and the UK will not fall enough will
not fall anywhere near Target
and that a lot more work will have to be
done by monetary policy authorities in
both cases I don't know how much work
but a lot more than holding rates uh
where they are and I personally uh you
know look at break-even inflation but if
I'm trying to work out what's actually
going to happen to inflation my favorite
expectation measures are what firms are
saying yeah I mean
consumers I'm not even sure they
understand the question
with firms I find that much more
reliable than any market-based match
interesting right
right and did you want to respond to
John's uh points about the annual
responded okay very good excellent
Charles any comments on this
I think the public sector wages point is
is very critical and private sector
wages are rising my understanding is
it's about six percent per annum and
given what's happening and there's still
very tight labor markets I don't see
them coming down much next year we've
already got a virtually historically
High differential
between private and public sector wages
and to go pushing this yet another I
think will lead to some kind of
effectively explosion and I think will
be deleterious in virtually every way I
have to say that I would definitely
advise a government to and not to allow
public sector wages to fall that much
further behind private sector wages a EG
at least five percent per annum for five
percent next year and find the measures
to finance the uh the deficit
through other other means and if that
means higher taxation uh so be it and
one of the things I would very much like
to see is that I think the government
should say and say now that when Energy
prices come down as they will
uh it the market prices the prices of
consumer pays will not come down that
much because they will raise taxes in
order to effectively keep the budget
deficit down and keep uh inter prices or
the consumer pays high so that there's a
marketing incentive for everybody
to economize uh on on carbon
can I just ask you in that I mean one of
the things that this inflation shock is
going to help us with is our debt GDP
ratio two three years out is going to be
a lot better than it might otherwise
have been simply because of the
inflation shock yeah I think what
happens when we will reverse it yeah
when we reverse it through high interest
rates and get the inflation down yeah
then all the benefit will go
higherly in the other direction
you very much Deanne quickly
um I actually disagree with that about
public sector wages I think that the
public sector
ought to be setting an example the
government needs to set an example there
I guess I would also stress that public
sector employees have a fantastic
pension that most of the rest of the
country doesn't have and that's actually
worth a lot when it's calculated so I
might go somewhere between whatever the
public sector the pay group say
and two percent but I I think it's
important to keep the lid on on that I
also am not sure although the rate of
increase has been higher in the public
and the private than the public sector
the last data I remember seeing it was
still at the absolute level of wages was
average level was higher in the public
than in the private but then their mix
effects and so I I'd have to look at the
at the data on that I think the I just
pick up couple of quick things on the
pace of QT
I think as fast as possible as Willem
said is is the answer to that it is
right and in my view certainly to uh to
go with the short guilds first and to
think about the interest rate
um
element of that and maybe even look at
the tiered
Reserve situation which I think Charlie
has mentioned and Paul Tucker has
written an interesting paper on and on
the the Japanese question
although I'm a great fan of Japanese
Gardens and I have Bonsai myself I never
understood the Japanese economic
situation I think it is somewhat Suey
generous it's a huge economy but it has
had a long period of deflation I I think
there is a lot of path dependency in
inflation or deflation in this case so
it's hard for me to say whether whether
they will need to move interest rates in
line with with other countries I think
that's not the case in the UK we really
do have to look at comparative interest
rates here thinking about what effect it
might have on Sterling incredibly loyal
domestic investors in in Japan very much
so uh Willem uh any reactions to those
questions or are the final point you
want to make
um
just that have that inflation will be
benefiting from base effects of energy
prices and shipping costs just as the
headline inflation
was upside distorted
um uh early in about about a year ago
from from base effects the other way
around but um we should not
underestimate I think the likely
Persistence of above Target
um broadly based inflation
both
in the markets for goods and services
and in the labor market
and so I think that as regards Public
Safety ages
they should be part of the package of
fiscal tightening dentist government is
supposed to deliver
um whether I would prefer to do it
through higher taxes or other
because public spending cuts elsewhere
or below
uh
below inflation increases in payments
um I I don't know I think that it should
really depend on the specifics
of the individual sub sector in the
economy I don't think a uniform policy
is necessarily
required here but it's going to be
painful
and there's no way to get rid of
inflation except through a period of
uh hopefully not too prolong pain but
it's certainly a couple of years of pain
well I'm well thank you unfortunately
I'm afraid we've we've come to the
conclusion
um firstly uh let me uh thank
them for bringing this idea and for a
brilliant opening forecast thank you
very much Eric and the whole team that's
here can I also thank our brilliant
panelists both online and in the
audience uh and in the the um the room
here
um really stimulating responses and
um but lots of questions still to answer
including a question about sort of new
kinds of macroeconomic policy we'll have
to come back to the future and then
finally if I could thank the audience
online for a whole bunch of questions
still coming in actually and the
audience here for your participation and
uh your questions as well thank you very
much so thanks to everyone
[Applause]